it's naomi smalls world and we are all
just living in it i'm so excited to talk
to you here on at canada pride thank you
for joining me
oh thank you so much for having me et
canada
super happy to be oh
canada i'm super excited
i was gonna ask you how you were doing
during
such a strange time um but i think i
know the answer and the answer is you've
been spending the time
wisely you have been very very creative
a small world show that's so exciting i
know people are so excited for this
the opening number is called the birth
of venus and it features songs from
uh beyonce and kanye west is this
really a rebirth for naomi smalls
i wouldn't even necessarily say it's a
rebirth of naomi smalls i think it's a
small world show could kind of be viewed
in that way
entirely this is my very first solo
project
it's really refreshing to like have
something
that is my independent i have all
full creative control and this pandemic
is
kind of what pushed me to do that you
know sometimes
uh drag performers when they're on
rupaul's drag race they're
really seen as one type of drag
and you know somebody like naomi i know
that you are able to do
all kinds of things yes you are like one
of the most stunning queens to ever walk
in the work room do you
think this is kind of going to give some
people some insight
into what naomi is capable of i feel
like i've really
like put my stamp on the drag race world
but
i would be doing myself a disfavor
if i only just let that be the only
thing that people knew me as
because it's not my it's not my control
it's not my edit
it's not necessarily a huge genuine
representation of me because it is a
competition
and i hope that like what i'm doing now
and
it just pushes people to who are on the
show
to think about the next step of like
what they want to do
how they're going to use this platform
your hands are in
every aspect of this i'm such a control
freak
and if i had it my way i'd be in the
editing room of rupaul's drag race like
deciding what people got to see of me
but i think it was actually really
exciting to do this because i got to
work with all the people that
i'm constantly trying to impress like my
best friends and my
um like mentors i look up to i just
spoke to sasha velour maybe about
two weeks ago we had a little chat here
on at canada pride um
obsessed sasha i'm just such a huge fan
of sasha she's such a
such a powerhouse in the drag world and
has really created her own
way and i think as i was saying that's
just so important to
create your own dynasty create your own
legacy through this seeing her show
smoke and mirrors
like really like opened a spark in me i
was like oh
i can do this like you can really make
something so custom
to you and create your own message and
tell your own story
loss is a part of life and
with loss comes grieving you lost your
brother
before you were on season eight um and
you lost your father
shortly after um when you get off a show
like rupaul's drag race
you don't stop did you take time to kind
of
process everything that you had been
through emotionally and did any of those
feelings and what you went through with
grief
end up in the series i'm just really sad
that dylan never got to see
[Music]
myself on like naomi underdog race
because he was my biggest fan and we
were so close
and i miss him every day and then my dad
passed away like
right before i was going on stage one
day in uh
australia the small world show
definitely touches on
my experience with lost and kind of like
how i can twist that
twist those emotions and put it into my
art
and make light of the situation because
in reality they're not going to come
back but you have to honor them every
single day in the small world show you
are performing one of my personal
favorite
ever lady gaga songs dance in the dark
such a great gaga song why do you love
that gaga song so much that you wanted
to include it in the show oh my god
great question
so the fame monster honestly like i feel
like changed the game
i was like i want to say 16 years old
in high school when the fame monster
came out and
i was that kid that if anyone said
anything bad
about lady gaga in school i was like
screaming at them from across the room
how dare you
i had my brother like drive me out to la
to
wait in line for two days to get my
album signed by her
i was just like fully deep into
the gaga lifestyle it's really cool to
have that full circle moment in the
small world show where i get to like
honor lady gaga
honor young davis and kind of glamorize
what my mom was seeing outside of her
bedroom window
i loved the glad awards performance you
did with chloe and hallie
[Music]
it was so much fun to be able to perform
with them
was just so cool and it was such a warm
and welcoming and like inviting
experience they
had their parents on set and they wanted
to keep the
they wanted to keep like their body
count down so their parents were doing
their hair and makeup and i just thought
that was like the most
adorable thing in the entire world i
mean family is everything
coming out very soon is rupaul's drag
race
vegas review i'm super excited for
people to see us in a non-competition
setting because
you just worry about different things
and there's still a tons of
how the dare you things backstage are
like
really tense i don't want what happened
last night to spill into the show oh
it's billy
i'm entitled to be upset it's emotional
it's mental it's physical
there's amazing growth there's amazing
tears there's amazing fights
i am a little nervous just because i
haven't seen the episodes yet so i'm
gonna be watching for the first time
like everybody
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos